ok let's get into audience questions for
the week one that is increasingly coming
up in different forms is this question
of Donald Trump and the federal
government versus states when it comes
to shelter-in-place stay at home orders
and shutting down versus reopening the
economy and the question is it was
received received today from mark was
hey David if Donald Trump wants to
reopen the economy before state
governors are willing to is there any
way Trump can overrule a governor stay
at home order I did a bunch of research
on this and the the the answer to me
strikes me as know from all the legal
opinions that I've read about this so
Trump can do what he wants federally he
can say we're gonna extend the
guidelines to April 30th as he did last
week over the onion Sunday press
conference and when it comes to federal
employees Trump has certain authority
when it comes to international air
travel it doesn't appear as though for
example if Trump bans travel from China
to the US it doesn't appear as though
Massachusetts governor Charlie Baker
could say no no we're gonna allow planes
from China to land at Boston's Logan
Airport doesn't seem to be the case
Trump's designation sort of rules or
supersedes whatever a local government
governor might want to do there of
course you've got the FAA regulating air
travel is a federal agency but I think
you sort of get the point governor's do
not work for the federal government nor
for Donald Trump they are administrators
of their state and we have states rights
here so if Donald Trump says everybody's
got to get back to work and Charlie
Baker here or Andrew Cuomo or Gavin
Newsom or whoever says no we're not
going to do that it might seem as though
there's a very significant conflict
there and it might sort of become a
fight now the reality is that these
shelter-in-place
orders are not really being enforced
significantly by police at this point
other than in some cases where there
have been you know big gatherings that
police broke up and arrested people for
the most part and in Massachusetts we
have experienced from the Boston
Marathon bombing when there was a
shelter in place
when the Bombers were on the loose these
are basically things that are followed
by people not at the end of a barrel of
a gun so to speak and in in that same
way I believe that there is not really
any way for the federal government to
come in and do the opposite and say
you've got to go to work now and I'm
pretty confident in Massachusetts if
Trump said let's let it rip and Charlie
Baker says let's not that it's not even
going to be an issue that people are
simply going to do what Charlie Baker
says now the most likely outcome from a
legal perspective if the Trump
administration wanted to push it imagine
that federally Trump lifts the the
guidelines and governor's say we're
gonna keep doing our thing and we're
keeping things closed the federal
government could sue a state that
happens there are lawsuits between
federal and state governments very
regularly and the litigation would take
a very very long time likely longer than
the coronavirus shutdown would last in
any of these states and in the meantime
states would remain closed there's one
other element I want to talk about the
Tenth Amendment has an
anti-commandeering interpretation which
prevents the federal government from
having local police enforce federal laws
so for example when California
decriminalizes or legalizes marijuana
it's illegal federally the federal
government doesn't tell you know Santa
Monica police to go and force the
federal illegality of marijuana they
send in the DEA or the ATF or whoever it
is that they send in federal agencies in
the same way national guards are
administered at the state who is it that
the federal government would send in to
enforce at the state level that the
federal government wants things reopened
hard to imagine so on a practical level
I believe governor's would have the
upper hand if they decide to keep things
closed on a legal level it could be a
fight it's a fight that legally could
take years and would long outlast the
actual likely durations of these stay at
home orders shelter in place
non-essential business shut down sort of
thing that's my best
now one other thing to mention I read
one take online that said now you know
the federal government could enforce
that businesses must open under the
Commerce Clause I found no serious legal
analyst that was willing to to make that
case and it strikes me as pretty bogus
but if you disagree if you believe that
there is a way that the federal
government could enforce and open
everything order even if a governor
doesn't want to let me know I don't see
it I haven't found a single credible
legal expert that sees it that way